you see in the manga Super Saiyans
originally had red eyes Super Saiyan was
never ever meant to have red eyes so
where does this conception come from
well because sometimes in the original
Dragon Ball Manga Super Saiyan had red
eyes see but let's back up and get some
context here so every once in a while
Toriyama would do chapters in color
rather than use black and white simply
and most of the time he would go about
it like so draw the first few pages in
full color give up on that and then draw
the rest of the chapter in something
that's called limited color okay so what
is limited color well it was a special
more limited color palette that Toriyama
liked to use consisting of mainly red
skin color and then black and white so
anytime you see Super Saiyan colored
with red eyes in the manga know that
that's just the limited color palette
unless you think that that Super Saiyan
gray that trunks used was originally
supposed to have red hair to